- [Mark] All right, beautiful.
- Hi
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Hi, how are you, thanks.
- [Mark] So, how have you been?
Thinks of, it's been six months
or so since we saw you last.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Are you still
living on the street?
- Yes, periodically I've
maintained a cute couple
of different people that are willing
to let me stay with them but other
than that, it's the same thing.
- [Mark] And it's wintertime now.
So, it's got to be really rough.
- Cold, very (laughs).
- [Mark] You realize this is California,
people don't realize how cold it is.
- It almost feels like Alaska right now.
It was just a trip, but I'm hanging
in there I am maintaining.
I am gaining little weight, but (laughs)
- [Mark] You're still
working in the street?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And figuring it out.
- Yup, In Western.
- [Mark] In Western.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What's going on
with your kids and your?
- That's the interesting part.
Apparently my daughter came
out to visit me from Vegas
and I don't know who some
people decided to rob her
as she was leaving me,
took her house key cigar
and then she didn't tell me.
She just kind of ran to a friend of hers.
And she called me when she tried
to go back home her whole
apartments, raided, done.
They wiped it out.
Her, my grandbaby, stuff's gone.
It's a lot going on.
- [Mark] It's such a rough
neighborhood and a rough.
- It's beyond.
- [Mark] It's a rough lifestyle
in a rough neighborhood.
- And then you never know
who you are running into
or who's listening or who knows
how to get information about you, so.
- [Mark] And yet, you don't seem
to like well suited
for that life, you seem
like you're not using drugs.
- I don't even do people wrong.
- [Mark] Right, but you don't use drugs?
- No.
- [Mark] Which is makes it better.
- And it bothers me like.
- [Mark] One of the very few, right?
- Is this serving me?
How, like, I'm thinking
like, is it something
from my past that I don't know
about that's coming forward
or I don't know, it's just weird.
I would never think in a million years,
someone would go to my kids and her,
there where they stay.
I can see them coming,
maybe burn on my tent
or do something to me, if they were angry,
but they went directly to my daughter, so.
- [Mark] Do you think, I mean, because
of child abuse that you
experienced with your dad
when you were young,
do you think that I'm leading you on here?
But to me it sounds like
after hearing so many
of these stories where women
have been abused usually
sexually by a stepdad
or a father or a cousin or somebody,
it almost like rewires your brain
where you can't accept
good things in your life
and you end up making bad
decisions almost naturally.
- Well, back then it did me like that.
'Cause I got married early
and I had a, oh my God,
amazing husband, super squared,
Jehovah's witness family.
I mean, literally none of
them got in trouble, ever.
So, it was like weird.
So, to maintain a straight face
and be cool, it was different.
So, I kind of in and out
of the house all the
time, I wasn't cheating
but I just always seek sanity
somewhere else away from him.
And my sanity actually
was with him and ...
- [Mark] So, he was a good guy?
- Oh my God, amazing.
- [Mark] Yeah, you were attracted
to something more destructive?
- I was attracted to the streets.
It wasn't, I wasn't cheating.
I wasn't trying to be with anybody.
It was just the streets.
That's what my outlet
was when I got molested
when I was young.
I'd hide in the closet and
I'd go outside and play.
I just go outside and
that's always my outlet.
And it seemed like every
time we had, I had sex
with my husband, I would
have to go outside.
It was just like weird.
I was trying to get myself to be able
to be with one person and not
think about what happened.
But at that time, every
time I got touched,
I felt like I was nasty.
I felt like I was just
a little girl again.
And I could always see in
there, if someone called me baby
or little girl or one
word, that's what I felt.
And it would make me feel gross.
And then I get up and go.
But when my dad changed his life and went,
he went to a pastor school
and he changed his life.
Like, he's amazing now.
He's 56, but I don't hold grudges.
I can't make him feel guilty.
I'm not going to, because
throughout my pattern of life
he took me back and
forth to jail, fighting,
abusive relationships, everything you
could think about, I went through it.
And he toughed it out.
My mother and my children
and my girls love him.
They're like, pap's great.
- [Mark] And your relationship
with him now's good?
- We barely talk.
But when we do as relation to the kids
or if someone passes, I see him.
The kids frequently go see him.
- [Mark] Does he ever bring up what?
Have you ever bring up whatever happened?
- I wouldn't do it.
I won't do it to him,
because he's different.
He's one example of a
man who really can change
from being whatever it was
when the devil jumped on him,
whatever that was, that
touched him at that time.
He's an example of a man who
doesn't, who can Excel change
and do something different than not pursue
that, ive that all.
- [Mark] That's great that
you can forgive him as well.
- Oh yeah, definitely.
- [Mark] What do you think,
tell me if she's, your story
is pretty much the
blueprint for what happens
with a lot of women that worked
the streets is what happened
to you back when you were,
how old, like eight, nine?
- I was six, I started at six.
- [Mark] Six years old,
until you were like 13.
And what does that do to a woman?
When she gets older
- Kind of makes her promiscuous.
She reaches out for men to see
if she could even be with one.
It's kind of like you're trying
to test yourself to
answer a question to you.
Am I able to be in a relationship?
Am I able to have a man?
So, I wanna be touched kind of like that.
And I noticed the most people like myself
we've had multiple, multiple,
multiple relationships
because you can't just seem
to grab your head around.
And it seems like every time you get one
it always looks like the
person that hurt you.
It makes sense
- [Mark] It looks like what?
- The person that hurt you.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- And it's like, you're
going like, oh my God
is this really true?
Like, am I really doing this?
And it's I guess a shade, a cloud
that you put over your eyes.
And I can't really say.
It troubles me me
sometimes, I swear dreams.
'Cause I don't want to
happen to my daughters.
So, I'm just like what kind
of guys are these girls picking?
And now my 16 year old
daughter's pregnant.
So, I'm just like, dude,
did you like really this
happened to my pattern?
'Cause I was 16 when I was frightened.
You know what, don't do it God.
It's a pattern.
It's just repeat.
It's like my life's
already predestined for me.
And it's already written.
- [Mark] So, the father
of your 16 year old daughter's child
is someone she's choosing to
be the father of her child?
- I assume so, because I
haven't really got to see her.
I'm supposed to be going out there
to the Moreno Valley to be with them soon.
So, I asked her, I said,
what's up with this guy?
She sent me a picture of him.
He's not my idea.
He looks like a little
thug, but she's pregnant.
So, I told her I can't be mad.
Do you want it?
She says, I'm gonna have him.
Mom, we don't kill babies.
We don't, that's something
we don't do in our family.
You lay down, you get it, you have it.
She's simple, there's no
cut resonate with that.
We're not gonna kill no kids.
There's no abortion.
There's none of that in our life.
So, I told her, do you want me out there?
You need me?
And she's like, I do want you to come
when the baby's born, I
have to have that support.
And I'm like freaking out.
'Cause I'm like, I remember
me and do what I hated
for my mom and dad for eight, nine months.
I was almost due, you know what I mean?
So, I just don't want her to be a hot,
but like me I don't want
her to just let him,
be that, you're not a hump toy.
You're not that, let it be that for now.
You know what I mean?
Raise the baby the best
she can, but finish school.
And I'm gonna be there to support her
to the best of my (mother).
That's all I can do.
- [Mark] That's great, how
much does shame play a part
in your life after something
like this happens to a young girl?
- A great deal.
I call her every day.
I can't stop calling
her because it's like,
if I was there I don't think
it necessarily would have happened.
- [Mark] No, not, I'm not talking
so much about your daughter.
- Oh you mean me?
- [Mark] In terms of you and your,
the trajectory of your life took?
- A lot because I tested drugs out
before I thought I was an ally.
It drove me crazy.
I had to sit back and chill.
Like it was just taking me
from one euphoric moment to the next.
I call and bug the crap
out of him and my mom.
I'd curse my mom.
I'm like, why'd you let this happen to me?
Like, you're not a mom.
I would just, obliterate
the story and I'd go
on and on and about it.
And then when you go outside
you don't want to be seen.
Like this kind of stuff,
I would never wear this.
I started wearing like boy
clothes, baggy clothes.
And I had a pretty nice shape.
I've always had a little
cocoa cocoa bottle shape
but I didn't know.
I didn't want it to be seen.
And if I did, my body
was pretty to people or cute
to people, I didn't want that to be no.
I don't want to hear that.
If they commented me,
no, you know what I mean?
Don't talk to me.
I always had a shield.
My defense mechanism is ridiculous.
It's still ridiculous.
Like I'm still by myself.
I don't choose to have any money.
'Cause when I stop doing this crap,
'cause I'm not, I'm not happy about
this prostitution thing, at all.
It makes me feel
like I'm purposely giving myself away
to just anybody because
of what happens to me or just for money.
I'm not like that.
I know I'm not, I have great jobs.
So, I know I'm working as an eligible.
Like I know I can get down with them.
- [Mark] Yeah, my question
about shame though,
was basically the shame from what happened
to you with your dad when you were young.
Maybe led you into doing this,
and now by doing this,
that causes more shame
and it's an endless cycle
of just destruction.
- 'Cause you don't see me outside
unless I really have to go get something.
- [Mark] Yeah, and, and
doing this without drugs,
is that difficult?
- Extremely (laughs).
- [Mark] Because I think the majority
of the girls are drunk
or high on something.
- It got extremely difficult
because like I said, I think harder.
I'm always a thinker and I, when I'm out
there, I really don't just jump
to every car that pulls over.
Like, I'm constantly reading people.
Because I don't wanna get hurt.
- [Mark] How many guys
have you turned down
that try to pick you up?
- A lot, a lot more turndowns
than actually getting.
That's why I can't have a partner.
I can't have someone that's gonna try
to press me, to make a quota or nothing
like that because I'm not gonna make it.
I know I'm not.
Because I'm not gonna force myself
to just be with anybody.
For one, you can't just come home
from work and try to be, I can't do it.
You got to shower.
And if I have a room
whoever I pick up, if you,
if you don't, you got
to get more showering,
like you're gonna shower.
I'm very, very, very,
very can tell my body.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I do, I will not.
- [Mark] Do you respect
the guys that pick you up?
- Of course I'm not gonna.
- [Mark] Do you like them?
- No, not all of them.
I treat them as people
because I don't want
them to do me dirty while they're,
while we're in the midst of whatever.
So, I try to make it as
pleasurable as possible.
I don't look at people's tricks.
Sorry, girls, she's not my thing.
I have to put my mind
in a different set to
even lay with them, so.
- [Mark] You'd have to do something.
You'd have to do something.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] If you're not
getting drunk, you to
- Oh, I have to really
really psych my mind out.
- [Mark] Disassociate it with something?
You have to disassociate
or something to...
- Really, that's why I'm
always doing something
before I actually step
outside, like I am a.
- [Mark] But it still must
be, I don't know what word to use.
It's got to affect your psyche, your soul,
your spirit, your something.
- It does because, if my
daughters and so many caught me
as I walk in the street,
I would freak out.
I will play it off so bad.
I would be like,
- [Mark] I mean, is it
hard for a working girl
that gets seen by one of your neighbors
or somebody, some family?
- I venture out like Figaroa and Western.
Those are areas that I
don't mean I'm more like
in the Valley and stuff.
That's why I usually live at.
I just barely started
being homeless out here.
This is just, I try not
to do anything out here.
I'm more (Nuys) area.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
So, you stay away from where you live.
For that reason, so that your friends
and family don't see you?
- But then most of them are
starting to work out here now.
So, I was just like, (mumbles)
My case manager actually was driving down
figaroa one day and saw
me and he pulls over
and he's like, tell me you're not,
I go, I am not.
Game face, you know what I mean?
- [Mark] Yeah, but now you're
doing a video on YouTube
- All right, and I hope
he never looks at it.
But total game face.
I mean, he pretty much knows about me.
He's my case manager.
I've had to fill him in on a lot.
But it's weird to even
have a male case manager.
- [Mark] I think people are very quick
to forgive somebody like yourself.
'Cause you're just
trying to make ends meet.
- Yeah, but I don't do
people dirty either.
I'm not like seven girls.
If they don't want to do it,
they don't want to have sex.
They might just try to take it.
I'm gonna do something.
I don't like bad karma.
I can't it's me versus
looking over my back to go
in the streets and
you're walking for hours.
It's not like you go out there
and boom, boom, boom, is there.
No, you're walking for hours.
So, nine times out of 10,
you're looking straight forward.
You're barely stopping.
And you have certain routes.
You take, familiar territory.
So, the person that you do
wrong, they're not slow.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] You can make yourself
very very comfortable.
- I don't want to be hurt.
So, I don't want to be vulnerable.
I'm not going to treat anybody wrong.
And it is what it is.
So, I get my respect back
the way I give it, yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have regulars
that take care of you and.
- I wish, I don't even
know how to keep them.
So I'm still like, I feel
like I'm still new to it.
Cause I don't, I don't like it.
- [Mark] I would think
you'd be a prime candidate
for some guy to just think you're the
- Some of them do they all say that,
but I mean I can't keep
a consistent phone.
- [Mark] No, but do you not
have some guys that just
wanna save you and all that kind of stuff?
I've heard it.
They don't, they don't follow through.
- [Mark] They don't follow through.
I also think it's more
difficult than just saving you
or getting you a car and an apartment.
I think there's probably
years of patience.
- But see, I don't want to put my hurts.
Like if I get with someone
new, I'm not gonna boggle
their brain with my past.
Because to borrow their
brain is gonna get stuck.
And at some point you're
gonna see behaviors.
Like they're kind of like efficient.
So, I don't even want to
put that in a friendship
or a client's mindset or even someone
who wants to be with me.
I'm never ever going to tell
anybody again about my past
even though now we're broadcast radio
but, I don't want that to be
a pain factor to be talked
about because if I want people to want me
for me regardless helped me for me
because I know what to do with my money.
I'm not out here, oh, as soon
as I get money, I'm going right there.
Every time I get a certain amount of money
I send my daughter $50.
Because she takes care of
most of the smaller kids.
So, I send something to her.
I'll have to, she's
like the matriarch of
the family right now.
She took my position.
So, I have to look out for her.
And once I do that for her,
then I try to go and
get it out for the two
because for some reason I can't seem
to get clothes or shoes.
Somebody's always on my stuff.
It's like I feel like I'm being followed.
Like what's wrong here?
I got a lot of jealous people
because I don't do drugs.
So, I'm just different.
I'm always upbeat.
I'm always smiling, if I can.
I try to stay out of the way.
Yeah, I stayed to myself pretty much
but I stays out of the way.
I don't like drama.
I don't do arguing.
I have seizures.
So for one, I'm not gonna let my brain
get all that pressure.
For two, I always tell a partner of mine
or whatever, I'm not gonna argue with you.
So, I don't think if I walk out
the door I'm gonna go
be with someone else.
I'm just walking out the door
'cause I have to breathe.
And then I'm gonna come in back
and speak with you like a
lady, because that's what I am.
And that's how I have to live my life.
I have to, that's how come on, I don't
have as many battle wounds as these girls.
Like I get some of these girls
and I'm like, what is going?
What are you guys doing?
The girls with the pimps?
Oh my God!
Sometimes always, I was one.
I'd be like, girls, like, come on
like you guys will not get hurt.
Like, you know what I mean?
I would, I was all different type of.
This life, and it's getting worse.
- [Mark] It's getting worse?
- Oh my God, I mean, these girls
like now they're totally
getting like young, young girls
because they beat the crap
out of these old girls.
They are toothless,
they're a little like, oh,
they use them to the gang.
Use them no more.
And it's done.
And I feel bad for the ones
who only know their pimp.
What are your gonna do when you?
And when he leaves you?
- [Mark] Well, I think it's
difficult for a girl to get out
of that situation because
she doesn't, the reality
of a life not doing that is very scary.
It takes a lot of courage
for girls to get out.
- It does.
- [Mark] Because then you're also.
- And I'm working on it.
- [Mark] You need to
like do what, you need
to get a regular way to support yourself.
You need to walk less square
life, which is hard, mum.
- And you gotta be
willing not to step out.
I step outside the box anyways,
and look for work ethic.
I'll go to temp agencies and everything.
- [Mark] No, I can see you.
I could see you making
the transition easier
than anyone (mumbles)
- Yes a, boo baby, you
don't know (laughs).
So, I mean if that opportunity
proceeds itself, I'm on it.
I can't, I'm just, I'm unhappy with this
but I keep a smile.
That's all I can do.
- [Mark] Your attitude is great.
These are hard times right now, too
- Hard call and not very many people
are even wanting to give out money, so.
- [Mark] Yeah, so it affects
every part of the food chain
including on Figarao street, right?
- Figarao always it's way worse.
It's like a million girls
and they're all hoping
at the same thing, so.
- [Mark] No I see very
few girls down there.
They're, actually jumping
into cars and driving forward.
- Whoa, now they're they say worn.
they don't stay by the
Florence and Figaroa area.
They try more to pincher down because
that's where more money is,
different class of people.
It's like, they're from the 82nd
and they're trying not to even
deal with seventies, sixties
because that's where
all the gangsters are.
- [Mark] That's where the pimps are?
- The gangsters, the pimps, all are like,
like there's too much
trigger ration right now.
I don't think we're ready for all that.
And I mean, it seems like
we're flopped with people.
Like where'd all these people come from?
I was like, dude, what is going on?
And then they come, I mean, nice cars now,
but none of they stop
they look, next thing, two seconds later
you see a guy's, come here baby.
Like, okay, now you want
to free, you know, come
on, it's crazy.
I don't know.
She's living, you learn, right?
(laughs)
- [Mark] You're living a crazy life
and you definitely deserve
better as all the girls do.
So, many of these stories are
heartbreaking including yours.
- Yep.
- [Mark] And I don't really
know what the solution is.
- Patients.
- [Mark] Let's see, I think a lot
of the girls just are unable
to accept what the change in their,
the change in their whole
life changed the path
of their life entails.
I think it's (mumbles).
- I've actually been.
- [Mark] You've lived
as street life and...
- Yeah, I've actually been talking
to like quite a few gentlemen
out there, like, you know,
wondering what their mindset is.
As far as seeing the girls,
what do you guys view us as?
Like I wonder because do
you guys watch our backs
when you guys see us
and you start following
us and saying (mumbles).
Or are you insisting to rob us?
I ask questions.
Most girls are just on this freelance.
I'm gonna go.
My pimp wants me to go.
I'm gonna go get it.
I'm gonna go back.
But I have to inquire about my safety.
(laughs)
So, I'm stopping guys.
I'm just like, dude, I'm gonna ask you,
are you following me
because you're gonna rob me?
Are you following me
because you're gonna try to hurt me?
Why are you following me?
Are you an angel in the sky?
What are you?
Why, because I've been right
here and you're still coming.
I'm gonna stop.
And if I don't vocalize
it, then they'll never know
that I know that they're there.
So, it kind of keeps
people from bothering me.
See, when you let people know, you know
they're around, you let
people know you know
you're watching, they kind of back off.
(laughs)
- [Mark] And I'm sure you
had heightened intuition.
- Oh yeah, it kicks their butts
- [Mark] It saved your
life quite often, right?
- A lot more now than usual.
I've been meditating a lot what I need
so, I'm getting more into myself.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned
from living this life.
- Don't be so quick to go get money.
It's not worth it because at the end
of the day your own pimp sets you up.
Yeah, you go right out
there and get it and already
know that there's someone
who's gonna pay you.
And there's somebody that's gonna get you.
And you're going to come
home and get your ass beaten
or you're not gonna make it home.
one of the two.
So, I'm never, ever, ever
this blessing safe place.
You can express yourself.
If people are listening,
people are watching.
Somebody might cross hold to it.
But the streets is something else.
And people are dying in droves, in droves.
I mean there's constant gunshots.
People are walking and getting stabbed.
You can be walking, it's bad.
It's really bad.
- [Mark] All right, beautiful.
Thank you so much for coming in again.
- Thank you, for having me.
I appreciate it.
- [Mark] Best of luck.
Hope you have a great year.
- You too.
- [Mark] Next time.